the House Intelligence Committee hears
new testimony today from Admiral Mike
Rogers director of the National Security
Agency and FBI director James Comey they
will testify in private about Russian
interference in the last election in a
public session yesterday Comey told
senators he was quote mildly nauseous at
the idea that his handling of Hillary
Clinton's email investigation could have
affected the election Jeff Pegues is
outside the Capitol with the latest Jeff
good morning good morning it was classic
Comey there were blunt assessments and
surprising revelations but the headline
was his vigorous defense of his actions
during the 2016 election but he did talk
about what he believes is the clear and
present danger from Russia what kind of
threat do you believe Russia presents to
our democratic process well certainly
that in my view the greatest threat of
any nation on earth given their
intention and their capability FBI
director James Comey offered the Senate
Judiciary Committee his chilling
assessment on Russian meddling is it
fair to say that the Russian government
is still involved in American politics
yes
the FBI's counterintelligence
investigation into potential connections
between the Trump campaign and Russia
opened last July Congress was notified
in March Comey said he didn't make the
disclosure to Congress before the
election because the bureau doesn't make
its investigations public was it
appropriate for you to comment on one
investigation repeatedly not say
anything about the other I think Mike
treated both investigations consistently
under the same principles but in July
Comey made headlines by announcing
Hillary Clinton would not be charged
over her emails without consulting the
Justice Department he cited an impromptu
tarmac meeting between then Attorney
General Loretta Lynch and Bill Clinton
her meeting with President Clinton on
that airplane was the capper for me
Comey also explained his decision to
notify Congress 11 days before the
election about classified emails found
on a computer Clinton aide uma Abidine
shared with her husband Anthony Weiner
Huma Abedin appears to have had a
regular practice of forwarding emails to
him for him I think to print out for her
so she could then deliver them
a Secretary of State his first public
explanation of the decision to tell
Congress was personal and revealing look
this is terrible
it makes me mildly nauseous to think
that we might have had some impact on
the election director Comey's that he
had two choices tell me what you would
do would you speak or would you conceal
according to some former FBI officials
commis actions before the election did
deviate from protocol earlier this year
in January the Department of Justice
Inspector General launched an
investigation into his actions in
yesterday Comey revealed that he has
already been questioned in connection
with that probe charlie jeff thanks